we'd like to thank audible for
supporting PBS Digital Studios do you
remember the very first job you ever had
maybe it was bussing tables bagging
groceries or working as a lifeguard you
put in your hours keeping track of how
much you expected to make and when that
first paycheck arrived you opened it up
and surprised some of that money had
already been spent for you if you've
ever looked closely at your pay stub you
probably noticed that uncle CEA's
portion is broken into two main
categories the Federal Insurance
contribution Act aka FICA and federal
income tax the first one is essentially
a federal insurance program for the
elderly and helps pay for retirement and
medical programs for older Americans
income tax rates have varied wildly
throughout history before 1913 they were
actually forbidden by the US
Constitution
thanks sixteenth Amendment as recently
as 1981 that top tax rate was 70% for
singles earning over a hundred and eight
thousand three hundred dollars and the
highest rate on record was in 1945 with
a top rate of 94 percent for the ultra
wealthy these days tax rates aren't
quite so high but no matter how much the
federal government takes from your
paycheck you should know what it's being
spent on have you ever stopped to figure
out exactly what is being bought with
that money you send to Washington each
year I think it's time to run the
numbers
this is Tabatha she works in HR and made
$40,000 in 2017 after exemptions and
deductions her taxable income is twenty
nine thousand six hundred dollars
placing her in the fifteen percent
marginal tax bracket
Tabitha lives in a state with no state
income tax so at the end of the year she
ended up paying seven thousand
thirty-eight dollars in federal taxes
nearly half goes to Social Security and
Medicare these taxes known as payroll
taxes are spent on health insurance and
income for the disabled and people in
retirement like them Tabitha's
grandparents
Graham Graham and pop-pop paid their
FICA taxes when they were Tabitha's age
and now they're enjoying the benefits
just like Tabitha will someday
that leaves three thousand nine hundred
and seventy-eight dollars of Tabitha's
federal income tax left to be spent the
largest chunk of your federal income tax
and goes to medical programs that help
low-income families like Medicaid and
CHIP that means that including FICA
almost 60% of Tabitha's federal taxes
are basically going towards insurance
programs $930 a Tabitha's salary
supports men and women enlisted in the
armed forces plus it pays for fighter
jets submarines and Pentagon staff
Tabitha may not realize it but she's on
the hook for America's loans five
hundred and twenty five dollars of her
income tax goes to pay back the debt the
government borrows to stay afloat plus
interest
two hundred ninety eight dollars goes to
unemployment and labor programs 238 to
veterans benefits like VA hospital and
veteran job training programs $179 goes
to food and agriculture and one hundred
sixty seven dollars of Tabitha's salary
helps keep the government running
funding agencies like the FBI border
patrol federal prisons and even the
salaries of her senators Tabitha spends
one hundred and twenty seven dollars on
transportation agencies like the FAA and
TSA and a hundred and eleven dollars on
education including Pell grants and the
National Endowment for the Arts
she gives eighty three dollars a year to
Housing and Community Programs
sixty three dollars a year to energy and
the
I'm at 51 dollars a year for
international affairs like the State
Department and Peace Corps and 39
dollars a year to fund America's science
programs which includes all federal
scientific research and space
exploration although it might seem like
those dollars just vanish from your
paycheck the money you pay the federal
government affects real people and
changes our world every day it would be
hard to find one of these expenses that
doesn't touch your life or the life of
someone you love and guess what these
numbers aren't set in stone you can
contact your local representative
national lobby groups and educate
yourself the money our government
collects and taxes doesn't belong to any
one person or agency it belongs to all
of us collectively and we should all get
a say and how it's bent and that's our
two cents we'd like to thank audible for
supporting PBS audible selection of
audiobooks includes audible originals
audio titles created by storytellers
from around the literary world
for example Ponzi supernova which
uncovers how the greatest financial
fraud in history imploded members owned
their books and can access them anytime
to learn more visit audible.com /tu
cents or texts two cents to five hundred
five hundred members owned their books
and can access them anytime to learn
more visit audible.com forward slash two
cents or text two cents to 500 500
[Music]